皆さん
メリークリスマスまたチャンネルのは離婚が変わりました
twitter を光年
すーってみてたらなんかある方が
いらしたわけねー
クオリティがもうねぇやばい感動した画像があるんですよ
どうぞ
あれ
うん
だーっ
これです
パー3属性球目
まずですねこの
首元の鎖骨日整骨
1月されちゃ股関節
勢子船迫つですねこの鎖骨この後この
キュンキュンてアプレこの関税
これがもう何か甘いすごく鎖骨があるんですよ
でこののとも解けですよこの俺の時結構あるんですけど
これはニュアンスところここは猫の数って
数ってなってますからね
ここの甘いスイカなんだ首の細田も非常に守られている感じがあります本当にいいです
ねー
そして上に上がってからのこのくじ位
福地ですよどーすかこのけっぽいこの
一面の吉さりげないハニカミの感じがもうねぼく唇
ボテボテなんでこう
うーん思ってやりますありがとうございます
そんでゾーンというに入ってこのゲーなんてくるこの花寝込みきゃーん
木場のですよその花もいいですありがとうございますそしてこの
左目からの優しそうな右目ですよ
夏カーヌーン
てもらってるんですごく癖毛なんでちょっとくれってなっていう感じとボケの
ナルシストかを表してこの4本の鉤爪これもまた
mice の僕指大きいんですごい
いろんなこだわりがあると思いますそんでこのサンダーのポーズですね
全体図を見るとこんな感じです
本当にもうねもろれすぎですよこんなにかっこよくないんですけど
かっこいいことに人がは今後のチャンネルのアイコンとして使わせていただくんで
あのほイラスト書いてくださったのかこちらの杏さんという方なんですけど
twitter を営まれておりまして上手な方で
本当にお世話になっているいるんでありがとうありがとうございますあのー本当に会
クリスマスで一番のプレゼントですよこれが
本当に書いてくださった方本当にもうねぇん
本当になぁ
ございます
ああああああん
ni